PRATEEK DUBLE: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the data
analytics session,
Building a Global Marketing
Data Hub on Google Cloud.
I'm Prateek Duble, Data
Analytics Specialist
with Google Cloud.
In my role, I support
and accelerate
data analytics initiatives
across our retail and CPG
customers.
Joining me today
is Bhooshan Mogal,
Product Manager on Google
Cloud Data Analytics,
focusing on Cloud Data Fusion.
BHOOSHAN MOGAL: Hey, all.
Excited to be here.
PRATEEK DUBLE: In
this session, we
are going to share
how enterprises
can build a robust
global marketing data
warehouse with Google Cloud.
We'll talk about the business
needs and technical challenges
that enterprises encounter while
building the holistic marketing
data warehouses.
We'll then discuss Cloud Data
Fusion, Google Cloud Platform's
data ingestion and integration
product, and how it delivers
critical capabilities
to accelerate
enterprises' journey to building
marketing data warehouse.
We'll also take you through
a reference architecture
with Google Cloud products
that shows how easily
and quickly you can
build marketing data
warehouse in Google Cloud.
Finally, we'll close with the
recent case study of a CPG
customer who built their
marketing data warehouse
with Google Cloud Platform.
Today we want to showcase
how quick and easy
it is to build a marketing data
warehouse using Google Cloud
Platform to drive your
marketing analytics initiatives.
With that, let's get started.
Marketing data warehouses are
becoming a critical component
of enterprises to accelerate
their marketing analytics
initiatives.
Customer journeys
have many touchpoints.
A known customer or
an unknown visitor,
they're all generating
data through interactions
across channels and devices like
email, websites, applications,
point of sale, et cetera.
These touchpoints are
generating more data
than businesses
can make sense of.
For instance, visitors are
generating web traffic data
while ad exposure
data is collected
across multiple
advertising systems.
CRM and sales data is collected
across multiple systems
as well.
Having a consolidated
and holistic view
of all of the data is key to
delivering enhanced customer
experience.
This requires organizing
and leveraging
all the data enterprises
have about customers
across touchpoints.
Enterprises do
recognize the value
of building a comprehensive
marketing data
warehouse to solve their
critical business needs.
So let's look at
the business needs
that enterprises are trying to
address with marketing and data
warehouse.
First and foremost
is Customer 360.
Enterprises are seeking
to build Customer 360,
a source-of-truth
record to tie all,
or almost all, of touchpoints
together to fully understand
customer journey,
behaviors, and preferences.
One key challenge is data silos.
Enterprises have data silos in
multiple databases and systems.
All these systems and databases
are collecting diverse data
around customers and visitors.
All of this data needs to be
brought into a single data
warehouse to transform
before it can be made part
of a single Customer
360 [? deployment, ?]
capturing as much
information as possible
around the customer
and its visitors.
The second key point
is personalization,
or the business need
making the marketing data
warehouses enable greater
level of personalization.
A stronger understanding
of the customer
through full view of
all the touchpoints
provide greater
capability to personalize
customers' experiences
such as shopping, browsing,
email marketing, et cetera.
Consolidated data also
provides visibility
into customer preferences,
allowing enterprises
to personalize with higher
accuracy and greater results.
The third key business
need is around measurement.
Enterprises are leveraging
multiple Software as a Service,
or SaaS, backbones for executing
their marketing and advertising
campaigns, such as email,
display ads, searches, videos,
et cetera.
All of these campaigns
generate data on ad exposure.
Collecting campaign
performance data
and feeding it back into
marketing data warehouse
allows enterprises to understand
the campaign performance
and [INAUDIBLE] optimize
marketing and advertising
campaigns.
The fourth business
need is around security.
Marketing data
warehouses are used
not just to ingest data from
third-party data providers,
but also to share data
back with these providers.
Security is a key need for
building marketing data
warehouse since customers and
visitor data, which sometimes
is Personally Identifiable
Information, or PII,
is shared between
systems and platforms.
Data ingestion and export
to third-party systems
should be highly
secure, as customers
have trusted enterprises
with storing and keeping
their data safe.
And the final business need
is around machine learning.
Marketing data
warehouses should be
able to connect to and leverage
machine learning products
to build scalable
machine learning
products such as
customer segmentation,
lifetime value of the customer,
purchase [? aspiration, ?]
et cetera.
Customer 360 data in
marketing data warehouses
will allow data engineering
and data scientists
to come together to
build machine learning
models for marketers that
can be used for activation
across multiple platforms.
So now we have seen
that enterprises
do have a clear need for
building marketing data
warehouses.
They quickly encounter a
number of technology challenges
that hamper their
ability to move quickly
and achieve these
outlined business needs.
Enterprises run into these
four key technology challenges
while building a marketing
data warehouse-- data silos,
software as a service
platforms integration,
data integration
needs, and activation.
Let's look at each of these
challenges one by one.
Speaking of data silos,
data is fragmented
across multiple databases.
Certain data sets are housed
on-prem across databases
and have existing connections
to bring the data in.
Data is also shared through
a different mechanism.
For instance, your vendor
might be providing data access
through API, or landing
that data on an FTP server
for you to pick up on
a regular schedule.
Data velocity also differs
across enterprises.
CRM and sales data might
be coming in as batch,
whereas website visits might
be coming in in near real time
or real time.
Finally, enterprises also
use multi-cloud strategies
so certain data sets might
be available on other public
clouds or on-prem systems.
The second technology challenge
is software as a service
platforms integration.
Enterprises leverage a number
of marketing and advertising
platforms to set up and
execute data campaigns.
All of these Software as a
Service, or SaaS, platforms
provide data.
Ingesting and integrating data
from these multiple platforms
become a huge challenge
since enterprises
have to set up
siloed integration
points to get these data sets
into marketing data warehouse.
Managing and maintaining
these silos' integrations
is also a major challenge
for enterprises.
The third technology challenge
is around data integration.
Once the data from diverse
systems, databases,
and platforms have landed,
there are clear requirements
for data integration.
Data needs to be
wrangled and transformed
with sophisticated
data pipelines.
This step is also critical for
building Customer 360, where
enterprises are looking to join
multiple and diverse data sets
around customer touchpoints.
Another example would be
that consolidated data
needs to be aggregated
for marketer and executive
reporting.
Finally, data can be
prepared using branding
and transformation
techniques to make
it easy for data science
activities such as model
development and deployment.
And the fourth technology
challenge that we see
is around activation.
Data in marketing
data warehouses
is used for marketing
analytics initiatives
such as segmentation, campaign
reporting, customer modeling,
et cetera.
And these segments need to be
pushed back into SaaS platforms
for creating and
executing campaigns,
leveraging the insights for
marketing data warehouse.
Similarly, raw data is
shared with partners
through multiple ways like SFTP.
All of these
technology challenges
make it extremely
hard to deliver
marketing data warehouse vision
and its benefit to marketers.
In the next section,
we'll learn about how
Cloud Data Fusion, along with
the Google Cloud Platform
products, provide
critical capabilities that
has enabled customers to
build their marketing data
warehouses.
For this section, I will invite
Bhooshan Mogal, Product Manager
Cloud Data Fusion, to
take us through Cloud Data
Fusion and its capabilities
for marketing data warehouse.
BHOOSHAN MOGAL: Thanks, Prateek.
Let's get right into it and look
at how Cloud Data Fusion can
help you address some
of these business
needs and technical challenges,
like Prateek just spoke about,
and help you build out
your own marketing data
warehouse quickly and easily
on Google Cloud Platform.
To get started, Data Fusion is
a cloud-native enterprise data
integration service
on Google Cloud.
It provides you an end-to-end
data integration experience
that allows you to ingest,
prepare, transform, blend,
and enrich data from
various sources.
It helps you build out
ETL and ELT pipelines
to curate data links
and data warehouses
on Google Cloud using a
simple point-and-click UI.
Using this, you can then
focus on your business needs,
your business logic, and
build out your pipelines
without having to worry
about the intricacies
of infrastructure
and integration.
This data shows you an overview
of Data Fusion's capabilities.
With Data Fusion,
you can load data
by connecting to
disparate data sources
such as relational
databases, file
based systems, modern
real-time messaging systems,
public cloud services, as
well as SaaS applications.
It provides you a
development studio
in which you can drag
and drop sources,
transformations, and sinks to
develop your data pipelines.
It also includes capabilities to
test, deploy, run, and monitor
pipelines, as well as provides
security and governance
controls for all data that
gets processed along the way.
Data Fusion is built using
an open-source project called
CDAP.
CDAP is an extensible
data application framework
which exposes high-level
business abstractions
and APIs over
complex technology,
using which developers can
build data applications easy.
All around the world
taking advantage
of the latest and greatest
of cloud infrastructure.
CDAP then takes care of
translating and executing
these applications
which you have
created using your
business logic
onto physical infrastructure.
It consists of a core API and
a [? runtime. ?] Data Fusion
is built as an application
of the CDAP API
for data integration use cases.
Data Fusion exposes
the wide experiences
for ingesting, wrangling,
integrating, and replicating
data to end users,
while hiding the details
of runtime and execution
environments from them.
Additionally, it also
contains specific experiences
for industry verticals
such as healthcare,
which contain common
data integration patterns
within specific industries.
Users build out their
data integration pipelines
using these experiences.
And then they can, in
turn, rely upon Data Fusion
to figure out the best
possible way to execute them
on physical infrastructure
on Google Cloud, and others,
without having to worry
about how that underlying
infrastructure works.
The key value
proposition here is
that there is a separation
of design and runtime, which
allows you to build once
and execute anywhere.
Currently, Data Fusion executes
pipelines as MapReduce or Spark
programs on Cloud Dataproc.
More execution engines such
as [? DataBlock, ?] Dataflow,
and BigQuery are on the roadmap.
However, one of the key
aspects of Data Fusion's vision
is to abstract these execution
engines away from the user
and instead provide an
adaptive execution layer.
This layer will then decide
the appropriate execution
environment to be used
for a pipeline based
on inputs such as SLA
and cost that users
can provide [INAUDIBLE].
Last, but not the least,
like we discussed,
all the processing goes
through a standard processing
framework.
Data Fusion can provide platform
capabilities such as security
through IAM integration, private
access [INAUDIBLE],, et cetera,
as well as metadata handling
the [INAUDIBLE] for all
the [? data ?]
[? warehouse ?] processes.
With these,
enterprises can enable
largely self-service
processing of data
with the right guardrails that
can provide data protection
and compliance.
So let's look at some
critical capabilities
within Data Fusion
that can allow
you to easily and effectively
build a marketing data
warehouse and solve some of
the business and technical
challenges that Prateek
described earlier.
The first one of these is
code-free data integration.
Data Fusion provides a
comprehensive data integration
toolkit which allows you to
build out your marketing data
warehouse in a code-free manner.
It includes a broad
range of connectors
to common data sources.
It provides a broad range of
point-and-click transformations
that allow you to prepare,
cleanse, transform,
[? plant ?] and enrich
data without ever
writing a single line of code.
Additionally, since it is fully
open source and extensible,
you can also build
your own connectors
with specific sources, as well
as your own transformations
with just a few lines of code.
Its seamless integration
with BigQuery
allows you to load data into
Google's industry-leading cloud
data warehouse easily
and effectively
without having to worry about
understanding all the concepts.
Along with developing
data pipelines,
Data Fusion also provides
critical capabilities
required for you to test,
debug, and operationalize
your ETL and ELT pipelines
in production environments.
All of these
capabilities allow you
to focus on deriving
insights from your data
faster instead of
struggling with technology
and integration, thereby
significantly improving
your time to insight
and to production.
With these [? full-featured ?]
integration capabilities,
you can easily build and curate
your marketing data warehouse
by integrating all your data
regardless of its location.
In addition to
common data sources
such as relational
databases and file systems,
Data Fusion also
contains connectors
that allow you to pull
data from popular CRM, ERP,
social media, and
ad tech services,
which are critical inputs for
our marketing data warehouses.
It can then
transform and process
the data reliably
and at scale using
Google's industry-leading
processing
engines such Cloud Dataproc.
This takes away the need
for creating and maintaining
expensive, bespoke point
solutions and scripts when
loading data from each source,
and ensures standardization
and governance along the way.
Its seamless integration
with BigQuery
then allows you to
load data into Google's
industry-leading
cloud data warehouse
with just a few clicks.
Another key aspect here
is data consistency.
Like we discussed,
Data Fusion provides
a structured,
standardized framework
for transforming and
processing your data.
This brings in consistency
in your data processing,
which leads to
better traceability
and governance, which point
solutions and scripts can never
provide.
It gives you greater confidence
in the reliability of your data
and the ability for you to
make decisions [INAUDIBLE]..
Additionally, the built-in data
profiling and quality checks
increase your confidence
in the data that you have.
Another key aspect of
all of this is metadata.
So as data flows through Data
Fusion's structured processing
framework, the
framework automatically
collects metadata about
other data that it processes.
Based off of this
metadata, Data Fusion
can provide a discoverability
and lineage for our data.
Lineage can help
you understand how
the data flows through
your organization
in a visual manner.
Field-level lineage
in Data Fusion
can provide a granular
view of the relationship
between various
fields of data sets
and the operations that
are performed on them.
This unlocks use cases such
as impact analysis of changes
before making them, as well
as root cause analysis of data
discrepancies environments.
Additionally, metadata also
unlocks critical operational
use cases that help you
understand and monitor
your data sets, and also
the processes that access
or update them.
Data Fusion provides REST
APIs to [? deliver ?]
and exchange lineage
with other tools, which
enables you to get a holistic,
end-to-end view of your data
processing.
Another key aspect of a
marketing data warehouse
is data protection,
for which Data Fusion
provides the benefits of a
classical data integration
tool, but just in a modern,
cloud [INAUDIBLE] way,
integrated with the best
security and data protection
standards that GCP has to offer.
It provides native security
through integration
with Cloud IAM, network security
through private IP and VPC-SC,
encryption at rest using the
store-managed encryption keys,
sensitive data management
using Cloud Key Management
Service, as well as data
exfiltration controls using
VPC-SC.
Additionally, it provides
built-in integration
with Cloud Data
Loss Prevention APIs
to mask, redact, and
encrypt data in flight,
right inside your pipeline
with just a few clicks,
so you no longer have to worry
about complex integration work
to protect your sensitive data.
Data Fusion is also compliant
with popular standards
such as HIPAA,
PCI/DSS, SOC, and ISO,
which are required in large,
security-conscious enterprises.
The last of the challenges
that we need to address
is activation.
We've seen so far how Data
Fusion's capabilities can
help you quickly build out
a robust marketing data
warehouse in BigQuery.
However, that's usually not the
final goal for a marketing data
hub, but a critical step
toward [? stability. ?]
Once you have curated your
marketing data warehouse,
you want to deliver
the insights,
such as segments to
target for a campaign,
back to marketing
platforms for activation.
Data Fusion provides
connectors that
can help you regularly push
segments into popular SaaS
platforms such as Salesforce
Marketing Cloud or Segment,
or even share them securely
with third-party providers
or popular targets such
as SFTP and others.
This removes the need for manual
point solutions and scripts
for activation that are
hard to maintain and scale.
It allows you to automate
marketing analytics pipelines
end-to-end, resulting
in an increased
efficiency and confidence.
With that, I will
invite back Prateek
to take us through a classical
example of a sample marketing
data warehouse [INAUDIBLE]
[? reference ?] architecture
that we have recently
done with a customer.
PRATEEK DUBLE:
Thank you, Bhooshan.
Let's look at the
reference architecture
to build a marketing
data warehouse leveraging
Google Cloud Platform products,
specifically Google Cloud Data
Fusion in the center.
So we will go from
left to right.
Let's start with the
data source's location.
We have divided data locations
into four broad buckets--
on-premise data, public clouds,
third-party data providers,
and software as a
service platforms.
On-prem systems
and databases might
host a range of data sets such
as CRM data, sales data, et
cetera.
As we said earlier,
enterprises might
be having multi-cloud
footprint, and some data sets
might be stored in
other public clouds.
Then we have third-party
data providers
that provide data enrichment
services and other data
sets such as call center logs.
Finally, enterprises
leverage multiple advertising
and marketing SaaS platforms
to set up and execute
campaigns for display,
video, email, et cetera.
These platforms provide either
raw or reporting-level data
for enterprises for analysis.
So there are two ways
that we have shown here
doing just these data sets.
First, which is noted
in 1, in yellow,
Cloud Data Fusion has a
range of source plugins
to get the data ingested
into the landing zone, which
can be Google Cloud Storage.
If third-party data
providers or SaaS platforms
are providing real time data
you can leverage Cloud Pub/Sub
which is Google Cloud's
fully-managed real-time
messaging service that allows
you to send and receive
messages between
independent applications.
Once the data has landed
into Google Cloud Storage,
it can be used to create a
data pipeline with Cloud Data
Fusion, in number
3 as noted here.
Cloud Data Fusion can be used
to create sophisticated data
pipeline to join,
aggregate, and filter data
to create a consolidated
and holistic marketing data
warehouse in BigQuery,
which is Google Cloud's
fully-managed, serverless
data warehouse that
enables scalable analysis
over petabytes of data.
This architecture
is also supported
by a horizontal set of services
to provide security, logging,
and monitoring capabilities.
Cloud Composer, Google
Cloud's fully-managed workflow
orchestration service,
built on Apache Airflow,
can be used to
orchestrate pipelines.
Once the transformations
have been completed,
the query outputs or tables can
be pushed into multiple systems
or platforms for activation
using Cloud Data Fusion's
target or sink plugins.
For instance, you might
want to push segments back
into email marketing platform
for regular activation.
Marketing and advertising
data processed and stored
in BigQuery can also be used for
marketing and [? executive ?]
reporting using
business intelligence
platforms like Looker.
Now let's look at a
recent case study.
Here, we wanted to share a
case study for a global CPG
customer.
The customer wanted to build a
global and scalable marketing
data warehouse to drive
their marketing analytics
initiatives, specifically
improving email marketing
KPIs by better understanding
their customer.
The customer had siloed
and fragmented data
across multiple systems,
databases, and platforms.
The data sets also included
CRM, e-commerce, web traffic,
point of sale data, et cetera.
They were also getting data from
a number of third-party data
providers that
was used to enrich
their own first-party data.
So the goal of
the initiative was
to build a 360 view
of the customer
with all the data that
they had, and drive
consistency and standardization
across their data sets.
They also wanted to leverage
marketing data warehouse
to execute personalized
and multi-channel campaigns
across a number of their
advertising and email marketing
platforms.
Finally, they wanted to ingest
the campaign entries back
into marketing data warehouse
to understand the campaign
and personalization performance.
They also wanted to leverage
the consolidated data
for their business
intelligence reporting needs.
So the customer leveraged
a modified version
of the reference architecture
that we just showed earlier
to enable their marketing
analytics needs.
They leveraged Cloud Data
Fusion to ingest data
from multiple
sources, specifically
from their email marketing
platform, and data
from third-party providers.
The data was landed in
Google Cloud Storage,
from it where it was used
with Dataprep for wrangling
before it was pushed
into BigQuery.
Multiple data
pipelines were created
using Cloud Data Fusion to
automate the data ingestion
integration activities.
Email marketing campaign
performance data
was also aggregated
for reporting needs.
Once the data was standardized
and consolidated in BigQuery,
analysis was performed to
identify customer segments
that they wanted to push back
into their email marketing
platform.
Finally, they created pipelines
using Cloud Data Fusion
to push segments back
into email marketing
platforms on a regular
schedule for activation.
The customer is now looking
at enhancing marketing data
warehouse further with
additional first and
third-party data sources.
With this initiative,
the customer
was able to further improve
their marketing KPIs.
Consolidating data in
marketing data warehouse
enabled them to deliver
highly-personalized emails
to their customers, resulting
in double-digit growth
in email marketing KPIs.
They were also able to
build a holistic customer
journey combining
multiple touchpoints,
allowing them to
deliver improved
personalization
across their media
and email marketing spend.
So in conclusion, we wanted
to showcase in this session
how you can leverage Google
Cloud Platform, specifically
Cloud Data Fusion to build
marketing data warehouse
and accelerate your marketing
and advertising initiatives.
Thank you for
attending this session,
and we hope that you
will take these insights
to your organization and build
your global scalable marketing
data warehouse with
Google Cloud Platform.
Thank you.